[Music]
um
how's it going bros my name is peter pan
welcome to lawyer
leave your memes on the reddit 19 year
old
yes i know it's cheesy but don't know i
just wanted to thank pewd
uh felix why did i automatically read
that for all those times how's it going
i did the intro oh
how wholesome look at that that's so
nice
oh i'm glad my videos keep you guys
distracted from the realities and
harshness of life oh my god he's real
he's a real person i am dick thunder
lord of chads
every sims worst nightmare and thumbnail
of pewdiepie's most recent video
ask me anything
i need to see your driver license sir i
need to confirm that's real
did your parents give you that name they
saw how big my dick was when i pooped
out
oh pop down i would assume you came all
right
you know what are you proud of your name
or would you like to change it
i am dick thunder dramatic music place
thunder noises dick noises
guitar riffs i want to see this anime
hey pewds as an expert in oh geez uh it
seems that maya is trying to clean
edgar's upper
he looks as a sign she's going to
she's going to lay alien eggs in him to
continue her
space i was like what is it now
god damn it everyone's like backseat
taking care of our pugs
now i know for sure if we have our kids
i'm showing them y'all just be like
backseat actually with a child you're
not supposed to shake them and
throw them on the walls it could hurt
them it could cause damage feelings
how could you do that what that's a good
troll
i'm glad you guys picked up on the
backseat i know they mean well but
like i don't know it's also kind of
annoying not gonna lie
logan was standing on the body i was
recording it for the vlog
logan paul yeah i i've been waiting to
make that meme because it's so [ __ ]
dated
you see someone standing over a body
you'd be like
what are you logan paul come on guy i
know good joke
me recording the body the person that
killed five seconds ago how could
yeah i need to do a meme movie it's been
so long there's so many good among us
memes
i'm so glad that blew up dude we still
have new
gen consoles to come out like this year
of gaming is insane dude
i love the irony of new consoles comings
out and like the last two
big games had nothing to do with
graphics it's like
it's just cool i like to see that i'll
make a looping animation for beards
i got 9k upvotes it will definitely get
into hawaii
i [ __ ] hate this
no you need you need a you got it all
wrong idiot
you need at least 20k plus to get into
the y this is the finest
prestigious this is the bottom of the g
fuel
the best of the best oh speaking of
which i got to tell you guys this is
important
important announcement 31 off g fuel
this is the biggest sale we've done in
ever so if you ever want to try a g fuel
which i highly recommend
it's no calories i think or low calories
at least
there's no sugar it's a great
alternative i drink it
daily i love it i'm so proud of the
flavors because it tastes so good like i
can enjoy my own flavor
if you ever wanted to check out g fuel
now's the time because 31
off is an amazing offer trust me you
don't want to miss
link in description other streamers we
copyright strike whoever steals our
content
felix i was hoping someone would upload
this
uh to be fair i have been taking down
re-uploads of the member stream because
those are
specifically for members stop
re-uploading them i will have to take
you down
but these no that's all cool and also on
the download
i feel like uh i never said this but
elena actually reached out
she apologized we totally buried the
hatchet
and i don't want to take part of any
more i don't know any meme even though
this is very subtle
because uh i don't hold grudges and
neither should you guys
i see there's a lot of people bringing
up it's almost done literally years ago
did you know this person did this and
it's just like yeah
no one cares anymore is that really what
you bother your life with
come on let's move on fan art
fart really
46 000 uploads of a fart joke
i've never been so proud huge peepee
huge
well done absolute mad lad deep brain
yeah i saw this
school is back in session the government
doesn't care whether you live or die
to be fair neither do we we do however
care about monetizing your face check
out the d brand face mask guys
good meme yeah a really funny brand to
work with d brand they've been great
good product very nice and you look epic
big pp automatically if you wear one
sorry i'll stop trying to sell you stuff
i'm sorry
the letter k in knight the letter k in
okay
tonight okay the letter k
in felix could gel
this is this bully this is so mean what
have i done to deserve
you know how if you think it's annoying
do you know how it feels to me
every time i have to spell my name
how i spell and then i go to sweden oh
shelburg oh great thank you
wait what is this took three weeks over
40 hours
really awkward conversation with that
but here's my remote control
robotic coco melon intro what the [ __ ]
dude
oh my god oh my god what are you
what what
[Music]
[Applause]
not
hey
what what gabriel mcfarlane
oh username mine again okay huge peepee
that's probably my favorite one so far i
can't believe this meme is still going
for those of you who don't know coco
melon is about to take me over
i actually want to say a massive thanks
for 107 million subscribers but then i
also want to say
not good enough okay cocomelon is
catching
cocoa is catching up at a rapid pace i
need more subscribers this is not a joke
i have a diss track but the video is
going to take longer for
for reasons i cannot disclose yet so
i need you guys to subscribe because i
don't want to pass them
before the diss track trust me seven
years ago i met pp man himself in
brighton
hey you got a rare selfie you should
sell it how about that farts
or edgar do you smell do you smell
popcorn
what the [ __ ] is this i'll upload it but
i don't
think it is hey i made this pewdiepie
style
among us character let's say is that 3d
yeah that looks good almost looks real
i heard they announced that they stopped
developing among us two just to focus on
the mangas one
to make sure people can enjoy the game
and the servers work and i gotta respect
that that's pretty cool of them
wires gang he's doing wires you okay bro
yeah i just had a lot of medical exams
it's really annoying to sit all day with
tapes in my face
well again i'm glad my videos can keep
you guys distracted with whatever
you got going on we all got [ __ ] going
on let's get real here
let's make this to the y pewdiepie will
cringe
so hard edgar's first appearance i gotta
check i gotta check this out i think i
gave him a weird
voice i gave him like a high voice like
what's up
but really we know his personality is
more like oh my god
i have no fringe shut up already
this is your new bruh my god it looks so
tiny
oh he's so cute
oh hey he never
he needs a lot of attention and won't
let us sleep six years later and get
wake up it's time to record a video
edgar oh he's so cute
what's up my i can't wait to meet you or
whatever
um i really really love it and guys
and dirt
again we need edgar cam we need you
too so sweet 2013.
you remember that again so you've been
around for
seven years seven long
years look at you now huh
that means you're eight years old and
the vet thinks he's even older
you have gotten the whiteness on your
face you getting old boy
you getting an old bot it's not on
camera what are you doing
come on just one kiss no oh we can do
that again you wanna
how do you feel if i kiss you now
you don't mind you don't mind if i kiss
you
that's so cute no ha ha
yeah shout out to scythe always working
hard i appreciate you man
for real oh i made a gift for maya to
hopefully brighten your day
she's so cute maya has two faces
like she's 15 years old that's pretty
old for a pug uh
she's a crossbreed though so she'll
probably live a little longer
uh however she has two two modes where
she looks super cute like a little puppy
or where she's angry like a grandma
she looks so old
look young old martial was 19 when she
moved to sweden to be
with pewdiepie she was the original 19
year old shout out to martin hey shout
out martial
shout out you get the shout out too what
do you think i go he's really into this
huh you really like lawyer huh [ __ ]
simp dude
seven years ago today pewdiepie gave a
shout out to an irish
small irish youtuber the rest is oh the
modern [ __ ] i don't even know this
guy seems crazy i really
i did an impression of whatever
it is he's doing dude he only had
244 views on that video was that a
reason upfront
he seemed really funny his name is
jacksepticeye
you should check him out that's nuts
uh i definitely want to do another one
of these because i did the video where i
i donated to twitch streamers or
whatever and i think a lot of people
were like oh he's really
cheap he only donates 69 which is like
well
yeah people need money but i think if i
i was thinking like okay i remember when
i started off what really bothered me
was that not enough people were watching
and it was so hard to grow your audience
it's like teach a man to fish kind of
thing like if you give someone a shout
out that can really boost off to
to get your career going instead of just
giving a bit of cash which is fine too
i'm not hitting on that but i also think
people put way too much
value and money in general and it
becomes the whole thing every time i
bring it up so i don't have to talk
about it maya
what we see what maya sees don't sleep
maya
you stay awake forever maya edgar what
does it say on the screen
what does it say on the screen again
light mode dark mode
echo looks cuter than maya here look she
looks like her the gremling there
told you she has two modes oh you're
winning philly
i moved the mic now you can go you want
to kiss it
you want to kiss the microphone
come on do it well i guess you ain't gay
son
so disappointed look how drowsy is he's
so out of it
everyone would be like oh edgar's so
cute he's asleep yeah he sleeps during
the day
then he goes [ __ ] crazy uh oh no
felix just done it to a girl
during snowstorm september kind of snug
no no no no no hey now since september
is just a start
we out here we're doing no no not
november you with me
you with me can you do it crewmate there
is one imposter among us
it took me so long what the [ __ ]
is controlling us all this time i'm just
giving peeps out left and right
you know what big pee pees do they pay
pewdiepies pixeling of course
actually we just had a big update on
pewdiepie's pixeling so if you want to
check it out it's really cool the
developers worked really hard on it
it's definitely worth revisiting
pewdiepie pixellings unless
you haven't already because it's a
genuinely solid game and i i don't know
check it out edgar camp maya maya and
edgar yeah they're so
cute you guys are so cute i have the
easiest life i'm just
looking at memes this is ridiculous the
first person to see me must have been
like
i don't even remember what i saw dude
damn
i think oh oh this is good
yeah damn
ooh tip for your new microphone as
i work as a sound recordist and use
chocolate max on daily because they are
insanely directional they need
to be pointed at your mouth at all times
to get good sound
okay i think i already figured out but i
do appreciate it i think it's really
good like this because you can't even
see it
yeah and it sounds a lot better too i
think
even when i'm quite far away from it i
really like it but uh yeah thank you air
jack
i freaked your favorite turtles mountain
because eyes are so terrifying oh no
dudes there's one easy way to destroy
end crystal without causing destruction
from blind
all you have to do is cover oh oh why
didn't
everyone make such a big deal out of it
that's all i gotta do easy peasy we're
killing the ender dragon next episode
guys
oh hell assisted
wait what is that is that edgar
what is happening
[Music]
amazing well done edgar you did it
do you have emotions do you know what
those are you sleeping with your eyes
openly
are you pretending are you pretending to
watch the weirdest [ __ ] i've ever
experienced as a sweet is when
around mid oh i remember this yeah mid
20s
2000s it became popular sweet for
teenage boys to wear rubber bands
around their legs on top of their jeans
the more rubber bands you had
and variety in colors the more alpha
[Laughter]
you became to the other teenage boys
oh that's freaking funny it's true
because yeah
and then mid-2000s how old was i then it
was like i think i was in seventh grade
and it was like the time
where you start picking your own outfits
and your mom doesn't buy your clothes
anymore
at least for me in my age so a lot of
people just started
doing this and uh it you would have
this guy's doing it wrong though you
would have like baggy pants and then at
the bottom you would just like
strap it in so it it would look cool but
then you have the people that are
morons who think they're alpha that way
overboard with it
and it's not that weird as well because
uh i think people
that ride motorcycles do this so that
their pants won't get tangled in the
wheel
it has a utility purpose but obviously
it was just a dumb trend
i think the dumber trend in sweden and
i'm talking about this way too much
was when every [ __ ] on the
planet had the exact same sweatshirt
it was gl only swedes will get this
right
maybe you maybe for some re maybe this
is like the swedish pancakes
i think it's only sweden but it happened
all across but every
every guy had this sweater
everyone it was ridiculous you would
walk
look around in school everyone wore this
sweater
everyone had this sweater in sweden
every [ __ ] had this sweater
i you could not if you did not have this
sweater
growing up in sweden you were not
swedish all right
oh come on
why this is the best fat
art i've made so far yeah i can't
i mean i can't talk again what do you
think i hear
cool maya farts pewds you go away edgar
trying to fart so he can be
hey that's a lie edgar you can leave it
anytime you want remember
just tell them tell them you want to
leave tell them where you want to go
huh tell them tell them you want to
leave
it's okay do it i dare you
do you understand you're a cutie
patootie
do you know that
excuse me you cannot sniff into that
directional microphone
damn that's cool big creepy yeah
sick uh why does the microphone not look
like a penis
huh i can't suck that i'm joking oh
that's another oh that's a real
oh
oh my god edgar's so skinny there rest
remind pewds how edgar look
like you're so tiny
you're so fat now oh you got a diet dude
okay you want to thank the the 19 year
olds
for reminding me how fat you've become
huh you want to thank them
because now you're going to go on a diet
you want to say thanks again you look
you look like that
dick-stepping meme the ball's stepping
me you look like just like that face
well oh hey cheer up a little bit you're
making you're gonna
you're gonna make them think i torture
you or something cheer up hey
wake up wake up a little bit yeah wake
up hello hello wake up
there you go look you got to start
working out
you're going to have to do push-ups and
stuff oh my god that's another dog dude
normal people my favorite youtuber makes
vlogs
my favorite youtuber makes makeup
tutorials
my favorite
all right side edgar cam g
fuel cam mouse cam phone cam
knife cam damn cam cam
of cam cam cam of cam
[Music]
sorry you can stop now me five months
ago realizing pewds has stopped
making pew news me now realizing pewds
has stopped making meme review videos
this is so sad uh yeah i want to make
another meme review i just haven't had
time
pew news is done it's done i already had
the idea
that i wanted to stop doing covering
drama it was fun while i last said but i
think
i realized just drama is great for views
and it's great for continent
and it's fun i'm not going to pretend
i'm above all drama but also
i find it just not productive and
as someone that's been trying to work on
myself over the past couple months
i just don't have time to focus on what
the [ __ ] other people are doing and i i
don't want to
give that energy to other people as well
fix yourself first and then you can
start giving a [ __ ] about
what other people are doing is
everything surrounded by tambourines
nowadays
hold on this whole operation was your
idea
what's the next level for tambourine
help me guys the video
while i'm watching alone in my room the
video as soon as my mom
entered damn that was some thick legs
boy
yeah i don't skip leg day it's whatever
thank you thank you
what are those things attached to where
legs should be i
i thought i read string so i was going
to be angry no no no
this is the part you show to your
parents you'd be like hey mom look at
this
you like that hell yeah no what the [ __ ]
is this
download what the what do you mean plus
my shoulders are way wider than that
come on
oh that's so cute
oh that's one of the favorite ones i've
seen okay let's send it on this
this is sick all right guys thanks for
watching the y
make sure to subscribe check out the g
fuel 31
out that's it for me i see you tomorrow
guys take care head off
ah breakfast i'll be broke this from now
[Music]
on uh